ça tout le monde les gazettes et squeeze
et alors écouter aujourd'hui je fais
cette petite vidéo parce que vous êtes
vraiment beaucoup un demandé comment je
filme à mes vidéos et quel est mon
matériel alors que c'est marqué dans la
description de ma chaîne donc écouter
pour que aujourd'hui bon je vais faire
leur second set up mais disons que cette
fois il sera vraiment beaucoup plus
approfondies je vais vous donner les les
références du tout ce que j'ai bon sauf
les trucs dont je les ai pas et je pense
que voilà vous allez être contents alors
c'est parti donc encore on commence tout
de suite avec mon clavier donc donc
c'est rétro éclairé en rouge
donc là on a une touche qui permet de la
luminosité 0 niveau 1 niveau 2 on a un
écran là pour choisir pour choisir les
chansons donc là par exemple choisi le
profil après on peut on peut chanter une
chanson une game et tout est ici on a
six touches qu'on peut bindé voilà donc
c'est à dire que par exemple quand
j'appuie sur cette touche à mark rein
intrus
bon ça c'est surtout pour les joueurs de
mmorpg que c'est bien voilà mon micro
donc le voici donc il a un peu une
apparence de micro de studio donc c'est
un eagle tome 1 m 30 donc regarder je
vais vous montrer sur le site internet
si vous voyez je sais pas attendez je
mette la voilà donc vous l'avez
woodbrass pourra comme vous tapez
eagleton uem 30 et le voilà donc qui
coûte 55 euros le clavier contre lui y
coûte 60 entre ça entre 55 et 70 euros
fin soit 170 euros ça dépend où le
trouver
ensuite ma souris donc c'est une souris
de merde que j'ai eues en achetant mon
ordinateur donc j'ai eu les fronts apec
c'est pourquoi je n'ai pas les
références de l'écran et de la souris ge
mais par contre c'est un écran 24 pouces
1920 1080 full hd fois ce seront petit
écran c'est une pure merde beaucoup
d'entre vous le connaissent déjà je
pense c'est tout simplement de la double
c'est un petit écran voilà pour faire
mes montages des fois où là c'est
pratique voilà donc ça c'est la boîte du
micro au niveau de la souris salle donc
je vous dis je ne peux pas ensuite le
tapis de souris fort je les ai pas sur
toute la france
mais tapis de souris c'est un
steelseries
vous voyez donc c'est le plus grand qui
existent sur le marché
parce que quand j'en écoutais journée
sensibilité je fais ça pour faire un
tour sur l'arène pour vous dire je fais
tout ça enfin bref
ensuite oui donc regarder je vais vous
montrer aussi ou est-ce que vous pouvez
le trouver sur amazon c'est celui ci le
steelseries qck puce est ce qu'il ya une
surface non ce pape et c'est important
anglais france sans rien c'est celui là
voilà donc vous loyer dont qui coûte 17
euros 89 avec la livraison gratuite et
il est hors franchement mais
personnellement je vous conseille plutôt
un riser la sensation de glisse elle est
plus agréable
on s'assoit le joueur pc enfin voilà
ensuite au niveau des logiciels
la question qui revient sans cesse sans
cesse sans cesse alors soit avec eux
avec quoi tu fumes alors avec quoi je
filme je filme avec frappe non je ne
manque pas de vous sincèrement c'est
juste que c'est marc ta description de
machines si vous pouvez regarder dans
discussions de la chaîne avant de me
poser une question parce que vous pouvez
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur moi
donc je suis marek phrase voilà donc
voila mon google est votre ami voilà
machin là aussi pas mal avec frappe
ensuite non jeudi des gages de ppr comme
j'aime le dire je filme avec farce je ne
veux pas de vous on est vraiment à la
longue
franchement je le prends comme ça c'est
toi de votre faute mais franchement aux
cons quence appartiennent dans la
description il ya moins 30 personnes qui
me demandent ça devient très lourd
et puis voilà alors au niveau du matos à
l'intérieur de leur dit alors attendez
je vais ouvrir je dois je prendre le
micro
je suis rapprochée un peu comme ça alors
alors revoir donc déjà tout d'abord ici
nous avons la carte graphique donc c'est
une sapphire radeon hd 5870 sac ou 280
euros
j'ai claqué un noël de dans exactement
au niveau du disque dur qui est juste
ici j'ai un disque dur 1 g gare et au
niveau de la ram les bas d'un couloir
action juste là ces deux petits trucs là
vous voyez ces deux barrettes de 2 gigas
à 9 4 giga lan et personnellement je
filmé en prod2 katla mon prochain noël
puis voilà au niveau des ventes y loger
les ventilos classique de caen j'avais
acheté leur dit j'avais juste modifié la
carte graphique donc cédé journée alain
sur la carte et on a aussi enfin bon
voilà qu'est ce qui a deux qui peut vous
intéresser dans un bon voila j'ai un
lecteur dvd normal j'ai pas rajouter de
lecteurs blu ray puis puis voilà une
alim de base d'ailleurs qu'il faut que
je change très vite
si vous voulez vous acheter un pc des
arts génération afin de vous monter en
kit n'oubliez pas de vous prendre une
alim ça coûte entre 60 et 80 euros
mais c'est impératif parce que sinon
vous risquez de nick et vos composants
un mois je suis un peu en train de
piquer ma carte graphique car je joue
regardez même une femelle et tout
défendre ce mal robotique
ah ben ouais et puis voilà donc je vous
conseille de prendre une 500 watts en
550 parce que ça vaut le coup parce que
sinon vos composants sont un peu sous
alimentés je sais passagers performance
mais en tout cas c'est leur durée de vie
est réduit ça c'est sûr et certain
ensuite au niveau du disque dur donc hop
au niveau du disque dur juste là c'est
un wd passeport donc 500 giga donc
regarder je vais vous montrer donc sur
amazon encore une fois en bois amazon en
principe c'est je fais pas de la cuve en
rh pas payer quoi que ce soit c'est
juste qu en principe ceux qui gagnent
tout simplement
c'est juste que les meilleurs non ça
c'est mes enceintes on y passera après
voilà donc c'est celui là que j'ai donc
qui coûte 65 euros bon alors là proment
elle est là depuis quatre mois un bon
avant c'était 75 je crois message à
mettet 84 ac c'est de l'arnaqué à
regarder sait jamais ça jamais 10 84% à
donc si celui-là en version gris donc
sans son giga usb 3.0 tu es 2.0
voilà ensuite dernière petite chose je
crois que j'ai tout j 4 gigas de ram et
kadhafi a pris au niveau du processeur
bon je peux pas vous
on voit pas mais j'ai un quadcore 2,50
giguère donc voilà ensuite au niveau de
mes ensemble pour regarder ces deux chic
bull là que vous voyez ce sont des
enceintes avec en dessous la base donc
qui est assez grosse et écouter on va
être testée ensemble ce que je les ai
reçus il n'y a pas longtemps et je peux
vous dire que sa servante
j'en suis très satisfait vraiment très
satisfait donc comme elle coûte encore
une fois c'est sur amazon a eu plus de
40 euros 59
[Musique]
autant de conneries je viens vite où les
voisins bon jusque là bon ben je
mettrais notation si vous les après la
séquence des stages dans ça enfin bref
voilà maintenant vous avez toutes les
informations nécessaires sur moi donc
vous êtes pouvoir me poser de questions
bon voilà ou alors en commentaire de
cette vidéo mais m'en voyez pas de
message serait pour me demander avec
quoi je fais une cale et mon matos etc
c'est un peu pont alors que là je viens
tout dire est qu'en plus c'est marqué
dans la description au niveau des ans un
cd je vais dire les références alors 40
euros des philips spa 5 300 enceintes
2.1 de wanted eu deux fois dans sa boîte
plus savoureux dernier enfin bref
franchement c'est juste du lourd tout
simplement c'est juan serment de la
bombe atomique
ensuite j'ai à vous j'ai oublié de vous
dire pour envoyer votre console un écran
je dis ce que je vous le conseille
absolument pas ne fait pas la même
erreur que moi donc j'ai donc une petite
boîte
alors attendez je sais pas si vous
pouvez la voir elle est juste là c'est
une vga abbott nabeul za alors écoutez
c'est la grosse merde c'est à dire que
les mecs vous disent que vous pouvez
envoyer votre console à l'envié en hd
est tout sauf que ça peut que prendre le
format 1920 1200 et que les écrans
d'ordinateur en hd sont au format 1920
1080 bien jouer les autistes qui ont
créé cette japon enfin bref ils sont
super lourd et du coupage et donc puis
je peux pas imaginer c'est une qualité
dégueulasse en plus c'est un petit flou
que vous soyez en ça coûte 20 euros vous
êtes nerfs dès que vous soyez en mode pc
en dix matches et un petit flou enfin
moi je suis dégoûté au niveau de la
console j'ai simplement une xbox xbox
normal pas l'ex boxeur slim je suis papa
j'ai le casque de base de merde que de 5
euros et il me suffit largement pour le
peu de temps que je passe et j'ai aussi
ce truc qui est aux manettes
simplement il fait une noire et j'ai
aussi un truc génial ça paie une crème
solaire je vous conseille à tous les
gamers donc d'accord voilà alors en tout
cas cette petite vidéo est terminée
j'espère que ça aura été beaucoup
d'entre vous et que vous ne pouvez pas
que vous ne pourrez pas par mon enfant
que je ne pourrai plus maintenant de
poser de questions ou alors je répondrai
pas de maintenant vous êtes prévenus je
ne répondrai plus parce que la voir avec
sap et le foutage de gueule
avec ceci vous me posez une question
comme ça avec moi tu fus marcel là c'est
quelqu'un de la rue dit je vous promets
bon évidemment on va lier évidemment là
il ya encore un petit malin en plus je
dis là qu'il rencontre qui va dire avec
peut être le film dans les commentaires
celui qui ose mettre ça je le supprimer
jeu le bloc l'école à la blague la
renaissance et les gens disaient qu au
bout d'un moment quand je dis lui la
façon d'un petit ver ikee à mettre ça et
tu vous mettez exactement ce que je dis
barrois 6 super lourd vous offrant voilà
c'est marrant une vidéo la deuxième
boucle à la troisième ça passera pas
bref arrêtez si vous voulez vous
humilier devant les dents tout le monde
la regarde cette vidéo ne fait pas ça
voilà en tout cas j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura aidé et qui maintenant
vous n'hésiterez pas à acheter
d'ailleurs ce micro et très bon vraiment
je reviendrai dessus vous verrez niveau
des réglages ya rien à faire parler
comme ça paypal temps plein et à la
barre garder attendait mon nom va pas
faire de petits tests les tests vous
voyez des rallyes dont jean-marie le
nouveau des logiciels j'enregistre ma
voix avec audacity je fais le montage
avec sony vegas pro 10 ou sony vegas
movie studio 10 ce qui est à peu près
pareil souffler ses moyens mais c'est
plus facile à craquer et puis voilà
alors écoutez je vous dis à bientôt tout
le monde j'espère en tout cas que
maintenant vous êtes tous au point sur
mon matos que vous n'aurez plus de
questions derrière je crois que gérant
d'oublier non j'en oublie donc je vous
dis à bientôt pour une prochaine
nouvelle vidéo là je vais faire le rando
commentaires y regarder l'instrument
objets pour le faire j'ai acheté 80 à
cause de ça que vous vous rendez compte
80 euros à ça comme ça mais c'est un
vraiment enfin bon ça on en parlera tout
à l'heure dans le monde a commenté rich
ou mumbai